[Music]
he's bragging really such a bad thing I
got a perfect 3 star rating and every
one of Mario Kart 8 scum there's nothing
wrong with feeling a bit of pride for
that or gloating non-stop to my
coworkers none at all I didn't make this
video just to show off my mad karting
skills I've come to tell you if the
dozens of hours I spent fighting for
every checkered flag was worth it or if
I wasted my time like I am so often
guilty of just a heads up there will be
spoilers in this video wait did I just
say that it's Mario Kart for Christ's
sake
I feel like I'm talking about Game of
Thrones over here all right back to
business
there are tons of unlockables in Mario
Kart 8 most of your hard work is paid
back in the form of extra characters and
fancy ways to customize your Kart so my
goal before writing my review was to see
exactly what you earn for conquering
every Cup surely considering what a
pain-in-the-butt it is the game must
give you something incredible right well
no not even close
after cursing and sweating and cursing
some more my coworker max Hulbert and I
finally got first and the last Cup we
needed to pass and what do we get
nothing absolutely nothing at all sure
we got a gold cart for getting at least
one star in every Cup but for three
stars squadoosh and that was like a kick
in the shins shouldn't there have been
some crazy prize for mastering Mario
Kart 8 the game should have bestowed me
with the 200cc karts or a proper
ballerina or characters who weren't
stupid babies something worked my time
so I was a bit miffed why did I spend so
much time getting first in every race I
wasn't gonna get anything tangible for
my efforts but then I started thinking
deeper about this situation as I
normally do Mario Kart 8 is one of the
best games I've played this year and I
had a ridiculous amount of fun trying to
get three stars it's so satisfying power
sliding through every turn boosting off
every bump and chucking green shells of
the suckers on my tail
when I had victory snatched away from me
it forced me to rededicate myself what
could I have done to perform better
unlike most Mario Kart games skill is
way more important than items so I
always looked with Dana when I failed
but I've taken a turn sharper or nailed
a tricky shortcut whatever the reason
that I came up short it was my fault and
I enjoyed trying to improve so should
you try to get all three stars I would
definitely recommend it I don't play
games for some forgettable
inconsequential rewards that kind of
stuff is just a distraction and Mario
Kart 8 the reward comes from mastering
courses from pushing yourself to improve
and nothing made me happier than finally
coming out on top unlockable stuff isn't
what makes games appealing I love that
Mario Kart 8 showed how gripping games
can be without having to thrive me with
prizes to keep me playing
[Music]